آمل أن تكون محنة شاريكا ويليامز
المروعة على وشك أن تنتهي
الممرضة التي تعتني بالمسنين في
دار لرعاية المسنين في تينيسي عندما
كانت في أعمق آلام فيروس كورونا
، كان عليها أن تقاوم أفكار
التخطيط لجنازتها
[موسيقى]
باستخدام  يتم تشخيص إصابة عشرات الآلاف من الأمريكيين
بفيروس كورونا
يوميًا والمئات يموتون كل يوم ، وهناك
أيضًا عدد متزايد من الأشخاص
يتعافون من كوفاك 19:00 وما
يمرون به يمكن أن يكون بمثابة
دليل للملايين كيف تعرف
متى '  إعادة الخروج منه
أهم الأشياء التي يجب البحث عنها بشكل أفضل هي
التحسينات في د.
يقول مايكل مينا من جامعة هارفارد أيضًا أنه
إذا خرجت من الفيروس ،
فقد يبدأ السعال الجاف في رفع
الحمى ، لكنه يحذر من أنه
قد يكون لديك أيضًا إشارات خاطئة
للشفاء لا تنخدع بيوم واحد
جيد  تأكد
حقًا من أنك تقاوم هذا الفيروس حقًا
وتضعه خلفك ، وعادة ما يستغرق
ذلك عدة أيام ثلاثة أو أربعة أو خمسة
أيام من الشعور المستمر
بالتحسن وتحسين طاقتك وتحسين
تنفسك ، ثم هناك
مريض يتعافى  يسمي تأثير Rip Van
Winkle ،
قضى David Lat 17 يومًا في المستشفى
وظل على جهاز التنفس الصناعي لمدة ستة أيام
دون أن أعرف ذلك ، لكنني عدت
من جهاز التنفس الصناعي ، لقد
عدت للتو إلى ما كنت
أتحدث عنه قبل ذلك.  ذهبت
إلى جهاز التنفس الصناعي على الرغم من مرور
أسبوع ، طلبت من زوجي إحضار
بعض الكتب إلى المستشفى ، لذلك
سألته ، هل أحضرت هذه الكتب ،
إلا أنني لم أفجرها حقًا  ومع ذلك ،
يقول الخبراء إن فقدان الذاكرة أو الهذيان في
تعافي مرضى فيروس كورونا عادة
ما يختفي ، لكن يتعين على مقدمي الرعاية
الانتباه للآثار طويلة المدى لدى أولئك
الذين عانوا من حالات حادة من الفيروس في
الاستجابة الالتهابية للجسم يمكن
أن يتسبب في بعض الأحيان في
ضرر دائم للأشخاص.  وما إذا كان هذا هو
الضرر الذي يلحق برئتيك من الفيروس
واستجابة الجهاز المناعي لهذا
الفيروس أو ما إذا كانت أنسجة المخ ، فإن
كل أنواع الأشياء يمكن أن تسوء
عندما تكون في وحدة العناية المركزة ،
يمكن للمرضى أيضًا أن يخرجوا من
الجانب الآخر بشكل أقوى.  الجسم المضاد ،
ذاكرة جهازك المناعي للفيروس
والتي يمكن أن تساعد في محاربته مرة أخرى ،
تتبرع الناجية ديانا باريت
بالبلازما حتى يتمكن الآخرون من الاستفادة من
بدلات المواد الخطرة التي تصنعها أجسامها المضادة داخليًا